how are you doing papas yeah i'm okay
you
you're even more ugly in television than
reality
how do you feel though about getting
older i think it sucks
[Applause]
i don't get offended by being called the
wrong name i do you do yeah who did they
mistake you for i went to correct no i
went to russia
that was that was really good
that was really good man
you be me i'll be you okay here we go
yeah pump up a little bit good good all
right
can you uh yeah i can't do it much more
than that yeah
this is me being you it's just huh on
the rock
all right oh that's good mick can you
make yourself a little bigger in here
yeah
what's your
[Music]
favorite position
ceo
[Music]
high five
ceo
that was dope this week in a secret
ceremony in australia michael jackson
was married for the second time that's
what makes his new bride special the
king of pop said quote she has taught me
about the power of imagination like
imagining that a grown woman is a
ten-year-old boy
look at this panel
if i want to see three people who make
tons of money and have no talent i will
not watch you guys i will watch the
kardashians and as
at least i can get free nba tickets
now
do you worry at all
that your teammates will be uh
will feel like they're in your shadow
they will be offended by your confidence
and by all the attention that you get no
no no no i make them superstars just
like i mean
[Applause]
i come out and it's my trademark i tend
to maybe jump around a little bit what
do you really think about it i think
you're making a fool of yourself
what is your biggest fear my biggest
fear is
sharks
seriously yeah but where do you find
yourself in a situation where you could
somehow be hurt by a shark when i swim
in the ocean
what kind of pleasure it is
i used to date this incredible looking
woman just
beautiful i mean we're still together
but she's let herself go
it's if they're an ugly woman at the
back going boo
what
sorry rude
what what's your name adam
kelly i'm gonna go soft on you like
every man that's ever seen you naked
you want me to be a soft uh you know you
know one of those twitter tough guys
when guys come and sit on the couch i go
right after him do you respect me for
that no i don't
your big dumb desk hiding behind your
microphone thank you for keeping it real
college yeah i kept it
out and then have them in front of you
that's punk no but then you can actually
just admit that you're wrong when the
guy's delivering because now he's
delivered and he's still trying oh yeah
he's not admitting that he's wrong
you are known to be a beauty everyone
says she the english skin that beauty
beauty beauty they say it is so hard for
you to look ugly so
i want to thank you because apparently
tonight
you were willing to make the effort and
this man was married to a great many
women in his life they're all flat now
for me i like a striker that makes the
difference lukaku is strong he's more
the the physical player that scored a
lot of goals aguero is good
he didn't say yourself not expecting you
say me liars they don't compare
themselves with humans
i've never been to australia you haven't
i've never been i know so many people
from australia and i wanted to talk to
you because you're amazing and i'm so
excited for you it's incredible that
you've gotten as far as you have with
your obvious physical disadvantages
unbelievable everything about you is
positive you're allergic to your energy
apart from my drugs test they're all
negative
[Laughter]
there's competitors now ramping up and
as you're familiar with byd which is
also on the west coast i think they're
ramping up production of their electric
vehicles uh warren buffett owns 10 stake
in that uh why do you laugh
trying to compete why do you laugh
have you seen their car
i have seen their car yes in fact at the
berkshire hathaway meeting i saw their
cars yeah well they are on a different
they're
tell me why you're laughing
um
you don't see them at all as a
competitor no is it a cockatoo it looks
a little like a cockatoo you're so dirty
immediately gotta
go for the joke and i didn't go for it
would it help if i told you yes it's a
cockatoo okay
and here's a funny one conan he's gotta
[Music]
as long as you go to talk shows they
give you the most horrible coffee i'm
can we have a drumroll
it's gonna suck if she doesn't like this
coffee
oh i can tell you don't like it already
can you shut up a little bit and then
[Music]
now norm i remember uh years ago you
told me that you were there for the
birth of your son and i always remember
and you said that was the most exciting
thing you had ever participated in you
remember that yes yes and then what
happened i took crystal meth
what superpowers would you like to
possess
i already have them
how many siblings did you have i'm the
oldest of seven but there's such a giant
age gap i'm 44 and the youngest is two
i'm sorry
two
yeah my dad had my brother the same week
i had my daughter
so it's kind of like my dad's having his
own grandkids kind of thing he's still
i mean it bodes well for me i guess i
can still you know make things happen
later on in life right
i don't know because i thought that i
would never want to do this show with
you now why
now let's let's just explore this a
little why
because you thought i was uh
[Applause]
[Music]
if we went to a movie together would we
sit next to each other would you want to
see between us you know what oh jesus
because that's a tough i want to sit
like nine rows behind you and just tug
on your ponytail you savage that's what
i would do
[Music]
you have this uh very handsome this
let's just be honest and say beautiful
face
[Applause]
[Applause]
[Applause]
i lost my train of thought
[Applause]